reopening nevada to 100 percent good
evening to you i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez governor siselak
getting that goal of fully reopening the
entire state by june 1st
the i-team's david charns live in the
newsroom with this breaking news tonight
david
yeah denise and brian this is certainly
big news and the news we have all been
waiting for
for 13 months now these are the big
headlines right on your screen
governor sisalak setting a goal of june
1st
to fully reopen every county in nevada
as we've told you in about two weeks the
state is handing over controlling
capacity limits and mitigation measures
over to local governments that's on may
1st
the other big news here the state will
end the social distancing mandate
on june 1st but again local governments
have a say about
how they will move forward and the mask
mandate
will remain in effect now right now it
looks like clark county will be keeping
capacity at most places to 50 percent
where we are now starting on may first
and we've just learned that
large gatherings in clark county can be
approved
four months out if there are less than
hundred reported cases a week and the
positivity rate is below
six percent now keep in mind right now
we're at five percent
and we're seeing about four hundred new
cases a day now the governor made clear
the signs
look good with making this decision with
more people getting vaccinated in cases
remaining low
here's what he said about how we're
going to move forward
to be clear this does not mean the
social distancing will no longer exist
in the state in fact every health
official will agree
it's still an important prevention tool
this just means that the state will no
longer be setting the requirements
the that authority will also now
transition to the counties
so they can make decisions based on what
works best for their local jurisdictions
now we've seen in nye county they want
to reopen to 100 percent
here in clark county though the clark
county commission will meet next week
voting on those guidelines which again
keep things basically right where they
are right now at fifty percent starting
on may first
the governor adding by june first it
will be two months now that people 16
and older will have been able to get a
vaccine
so far about a quarter of nevada's
population has been vaccinated but again
governor sisilak setting that goal of
june
1st of fully reopening live in the
newsroom i'm david charns 8 news now